die landesstraße 306 ist im schleswig
holsteinischen hassendorf tipptopp
saniert worden für autofahrer herrschen
jetzt erstklassige bedingungen für
fußgänger hingegen ist das ganze ein
absoluter albtraum einander schönen
neuen hauptverkehrsstraße gibt es keinen
bürgersteig den haben die behörden
einfach nicht gebaut
die mütter mit kinderwagen können ihn
nicht mehr lang die rollstuhlfahrer die
mit dem rollator
keiner kann je mehr laufen die gehen
alle auf der straße also das geht gar
nicht
aber in deutschland ist nur für die
autofahrer und nichts mehr für die
fußgänger üblich zu sein was da
planungstechnisch von seiten des landes
und der gemeinde gelaufen es ist eine
katastrophe an der alten hassendorf
dorfstraße führte bisher nur ein
schmaler trampelpfad vorbei nun wird die
landesstraße 306 saniert gesamtkosten
3,5 millionen euro
aber die gemeinde verpennt es neben der
neuen landesstraße einen richtigen
gehweg zu planen stattdessen wird die
fahrbahn teilweise abgesenkt und der
rand mit sand aufgefüllt die folge hier
kann niemand vernünftig laufen es ist
total schräg an manchen stellen gibt es
einen schmalen sandweg an anderen
stellen wiederum gibt es gar nichts
es wurde nur an die autofahrer gedacht
die jetzt noch schneller durchs dorf
fahren und weil es kein bordstein gibt
weichen die fahrzeuge auch noch auf den
seitenstreifen aus alles zusammen
lebensgefährlich es reicht nicht wenn
wir nur einmal nach links und nach
rechts gucken wir müssen quasi sogar
wirklich mit was zu gehen damit wir
gesehen werden das ist eben viel viel
schlechter als vor nicht passieren
für den fehlenden gehweg weist das land
jede verantwortung weit von sich man
habe nur die straße gebaut mit dem
gehweg problem habe man nichts zu tun
dafür sei alleine die gemeinde zuständig
die abenteuerliche planung hat
bürgermeister eberhardt rauch vom
vorgänger übernommen den ärger der
hassendorf bürger versteht er das muss
man allerdings zugeben man hätte vor
einigen jahren
vorbeugen können und hätte gehwege
planen können
das ist wohl unterblieben aus
kostengründen vor allen dingen und dann
hat man diese maßnahme in die zukunft
verlagert bis heute ist aber nichts
passiert und die menschen müssen nach
wie vor auf der straße laufen
es fällt auch sehr schwer ich ein kind
hier dann auch mal guten gewissens ein
paar meter auch alleine gehen zu lassen
so breit zu bauen ohne bürgersteig ist
für mich ist einfach daneben aber noch
nie erlebt die hassen noch vor bürger
fordern dass die gemeinde endlich
handelt und ein gehweg baut damit ihr
ort sicherer wird wäre der weg
gleichzeitig zur straßensanierung gebaut
worden er wäre wohl viel billiger
geworden